m
antoine comme ça alors je plaisantais
nos amis royal besoin ça c'est tout
balade saiss et vous non ça se passe
très bien entre vous je crois avec louis
saha je conçois ça fait un cours de
français un très beau couple
c'est très beau couple laïque et que
vous connaissez nos banquiers oui et
jean pierre kopp
on va ça c'est à ça c'est vous avez des
enfants on a vu avec la sans vous l'avez
connu jean pierre 13 un an et demi
vous avez en ce moment et c'est pour ça
qu'on vous a invité parce que l'émission
s'appelle tout le monde en parle et tout
le monde parle de vous à cause de la
pièce que vous jouez que s'appelle maria
callas masterclass la leçon de chant
tous les soirs entre tous les soirs
standing-ovation laurent vous êtes allés
aussi oui exceptionnel voilà rien à dire
je suis pas mal à marquer alors que
pouvons-nous ajouté c'est incroyable
après j'ai vu la pièce mise en scène par
polanski à auzan troisième fois obligé
de parler tout à l'heure mais avec fanny
ardant et s était pas mal oui mais bon
voilà c'était pas mal mais là c'était
exceptionnel si un seul spectacle à les
voir à paris en ce moment c'est celui là
c'est une fin d'année a fait venir
ateba sur scène donc marie vous avez
déclaré je reviens à la vie dans la
callas tu serais beaucoup moins bien tu
sais oui oui a déclaré marie je reviens
à la vie donc c'est vous dit vous avez
déclaré aussi depuis quelques années on
m'avait mise à la retraite persuadé que
j'étais l'aide bête méchante et sans
talent alors quand on vous voit
effectivement on comprends pas comment
des gens auraient pu penser ça au delà
du généralement ceux là je les épouses
oui bon ça fait pas beaucoup ça au fait
que quatre on y viendra au dollar audio
l'ajustement de cet autodénigrement qui
est habituel chez vous est ce que vous
avez vraiment flipper un moment est ce
que vous vous êtes dit bah voila quoi
c'est fini on ne voit plus jamais me
chercher oui oui oui je me suis retrouvé
seul au monde
l'aide bête méchante est fauché ouais ça
fait beaucoup
et comment qui est venu vous chercher
alors s'intéressant à savoir moi non je
suis allé voir moi d'abord il dit le
coût de chéri bon d'accord ça n'est pas
le pérou mais on peut peut-être faire
quelque chose vous êtes reprise on m'a
fait c'est ça c'est bien
et puis voilà et puis on ne nous croit
qu'ils se sont trompés 1 quand ils m'ont
proposé master class et françoise hardy
était pas libre
sheila a été en train de présenter une
émission tv ouais ouais donc donc ils
sont dix à valeur ou qui ont la dent
dure sur l'ailier parce qu'à l'époque
j'ai retrouvé des papiers de l'époque
nahon quand on vous parlait des yéyés
vous disiez on vous demander ce que vous
pensiez de sylvie vartan et françoise
hardy et vous disiez mais faut-il
vraiment penser quelque chose donc je
vois une espèce de continuité comme ça
c'est bien donner de la suite dans les
idées c'est bien connu si payet vous
marie laval evian pas dit où attendait
encore en vente par la banque entend les
la callas normes et quand même pas
parlant de cette pièce de tout l'état
dit justement c'est une pièce donc le
terrain stricte maliki qui sont les
génies alors moi je peux le dire parce
que je le pratique tous les soirs et un
principe quand on pratique un auteur au
bout de un mois deux mois on commence à
voir les failles on commence à voir les
endroits où c'est un petit peu moins
bien travaillé ou c'est ce type est un
génie
d'abord il a pris des notes sur la
callas parce qu'il a assisté à une
assistance et les cours vous le dire une
sommité voilà les cours duquel sont des
cours de chant coke que kallas a donné
pendant deux ans
à la julliard school à new york et il
était dans la salle en auditeur libre et
il prenait des petites notes sur rien
sur un geste sûr sur une inflexion de
voix sur une phrase sur guillaud qui
avait l'air de rien il a laissé reposer
comme du bon vin pendant 20 ans et au
bout de temps vous dites comme du bon
vin normal et c'est finalement au bout
de vingt ans il advient parler de
cocaïne je sais même pas ce que c'est
donc je peux regarder que le ciel
d'accord comme ça devient un peu chaud
je vais demander à notre ami serge
khalfon et c'est ainsi que la lumière là
mais on est dans une ambiance soit pas
un peu plus cosy alors donc vers une
hyper view l'hyper mieux c'est pas
compliqué on abat oui on est mal polis
et une interview vérité donc vous allez
dire la vérité mais boucher quand je ne
serai pas dire que c'est pas dit autre
chose que la vérité on a ça en commun
c'est quand on est oui au rotor gens là
me coûte cher et ça m'a coûté assez cher
notre carrière comme trois fois de la
télé c'est vrai moi j'étais interdite de
micro pendant 10 ans voit la house house
house a atterri à télé enfin bon bref on
voit le palabre dont marie laforêt
toujours dans votre célèbre
autodénigrement vous avez déclaré je
pense en parlant de vous et de la classe
que nous sommes des femmes l'aide à
vivre c'est beaucoup c'est être franc on
verra pourquoi vous le dit d'ailleurs on
y viendra mais je dirais c'est quand
même
thierry henry oui elle est là était
moche elle était moche plein de boutons
en grosses amandes en 1943 45
elle est franchement un bon franchement
un tir à blanc
on le suit une info nationale n'est pas
cet adjectif un tir à un tir à ben oui
c'est fin de série c'est une autre celle
là c'est notre nom c'est une omission
baden
vad
notre ami karl lagerfel nouveau job of
war car la gazelle
vous connaissez jean pierre coffe qui
les connaît pas abondante et m'annonce
allure cup laurent ruquier lycées beau
vous connaissez d'achat oui tout le
monde connaît tâche à tout le monde que
l'état sion connaît mieux on marie
laforêt surtout à mon actif bon alors
gérer quoi mettre des lunettes noires
aussi ça m'a avoué que les services il a
posé problème mais jouer ou même un
petit peu c'est pourquoi je dis ça pour
votre lumière pour vous soyez le plus
beau fusil ou un message mais pas des
imbéciles voilà comme ça alors qu'arles
regardez bien c'est une hyper view donc
et et donc vous allez voir sa presse et
vous arrivez siens juste après ça va
être votre hyper diot donc marie laforêt
alarie photos il me demandait d'enlever
ses lunettes elle a des yeux en avril ou
en mai il faut qu'un accueil de jour est
votre monture allait vraiment vraiment
écoute être sur ses yeux non mais c'est
qu'il n'est pas rare qu'il a dit au
téléphone ya 3 il est très amoureux de
vous déshabiller la marche et les
efforts
voilà ils n'osaient pas le deal est
valorisé en fait rouge s'est fait
plaisir et donc et lis souvent il se
marie laforêt l ordi delà des yeux
magnifiques c'est une bonne comédienne
est une excellente interprète chanteuse
je suis fou d'elle voilà je suis en
train de me demander ce que j'aimerais
être dans la tâche a enfin de caisse qui
vénériennes de vente achat tendance à
jean tâche à toi tu voulais être les
montures le mot pur joyau sûr c'est pas
mal tu peux changer de branche oui bon
on continue donc
moi j'aimerais que nous rencontrent
racontiez cette histoire formidable
votre début de carrière c'est un
véritable conte de fées c'est en à
cannes en 1959 au casino municipal vous
arriver habillés comme tout le monde pas
maquillée bah oui non mais c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire pourquoi
vous arriver c'est comme nous mais pas
du tout mais c'est vrai on en attendait
c'est une émission que j'appelais
naissance d'une étoile organisée par
europe 1 vous jouez une scène de six
personnages en quête d'auteur
s'il avoue rencontrer louis malle qui
vous qui vous je n'aurais pas rencontré
raymond rouleau oui alors parce que ça
c'est vraiment la mesure de notre à nos
jeunes amis téléspectateurs
oui on peut pas raconter raymond en si
peu de temps c'est le génie je ne j'ai
milité aux bleus connaissent et le
metteur en scène indépendante et
s'active alors on sait c'est le grand
l'immense en metteur en scène elle est
ignorée au théâtre avec ce monstre
ouvriers rouleau est exceptionnel barème
ou je ne sais rien ça que les vieux sont
là pour ça mais écoutez l'échangé dieu
dieu seul sait donc c'est donc sylvain
louis malle qui vous a baisé marie
laforêt parce que oui mais comme vous
pouvoir marie laforêt comme ça c'est ça
c'est pas marie moi j'avais dit marine
américaine s est déjà pris non non
c'était pas encore pris à l'est pas ils
ont fait du maine du chemin la barrière
ouais bon mais depuis huit heures du
soir tome ont été bourrées on a dit de
la forêt au s'est arrêté là elle a dit
je vais très bien s'appellera alors
marie on va on va pas faire tout votre
carrière parce que vous avez fait des
tas de choses dont on va permettre aux
lions s'y rendirent en messie dire un
mot de plein soleil quand même avec de
longs et maurice ronet jamais été
préféré à audrey byrne pour ce film par
rené clément vous le savez ça non je
crois par 1,6 ici assez dans toutes les
histoires du cinéma c'est vrai mais bien
entendu mais écrire n'importe où si ça
marche je vous dit ça par vous dites sa
part me destine on importe ce que j'ai
jamais pas l'information et on se devait
être audrey hepburn et jacques charrier
oui jacques charrier il avec brigitte
bardot dans un métal il voulait pas
sortir de l'hôtel et non on peut être
compréhensible et donc finalement ça a
été maurice rue l'allemande bailly sens
avec sur moi alors après bon il ya eu la
fille aux yeux d'or qui vous a donné
votre surnom albicocco j'ai épousé tant
qu'à faire rêver comme je suis moi bah
voilà donc les amours c'est là qu'était
un filmage vous croisez un pied
qui est on est en affaires vous croisez
vous des clés on se marie on arrive à la
corde demain quoi là qu'on ne sait
jamais j'ai fait certainement pire je
lui vends bien 4 4 voilà je serai 6e bon
pourquoi pas
bouygues n'y a pas de problème moi je
suis d'accord je te laisse ans
oui pierre palmade exemple bel exemple
d'un mariage d'un mariage réussi
c'était joli ça c'était ce que je dis
moi bon alors on passe sur tous vos
films ceci en voyou joyeuses pâques
marie-chantal n 4 avant finalement
j'hésite alors vous n'êtes jamais
approprié pourtant vous n'êtes jamais
approprié la place que vous méritiez au
cinéma finalement vous auriez dû être
non je ne suis pas carriériste des tout
moi gp j'ai passé mon temps à regarder
les gens à absorber à regarder une
attitude un geste un grade mains une
paire de lunettes
j'ai appris mon métier comme ça et j'ai
pas provoquer un rôle
vous n'êtes pas été élevé comme ça parce
que karl lagerfeld quand on lui dit vous
fait plein de choses vous travaillez
pour des tas de marque etc
car vous répondez vous dites-vous lucet
de l'arrivisme singer j'ai pas été
éduqués pour être une victime ça c'est
sûr mais oui parce que on est arrivé ce
qu'il faut être seul et contre allées du
but de la victime fera une victime mais
je ne prends pas non plus pour le com de
l'arrivisme non mais je ne compare pas
les au premier passage
vous savez je n'ai pas été éduqué pour
avis que moi les âmes et les plus
vulnérables
voilà oui tout mon problème c'est que
j'étais une victime en 68 au moment où
vous allez chanter vous dites je vais
chanter sur scène
quel cauchemar dans un an je serai à
pontault dame alors pente aux dames faut
le dire c'est l'asile des vieux artistes
répondent aux dames et maisons de
retraite maison de retraite par les cov
qui s'est déjà renseigné
comme générant sais c'est pas une maison
de ce soir ils ont eu sortie de ventes
alimentent aux dames c'est quand même
plus chic que ris orangis oui c'est vrai
mais alors on y sera en israël et donc
non c'est incroyable je devais finir à
pontault là dans un an je suis à
pantographe après ça vous vendez quand
même 35 millions de disques
donc c'était assez bizarre quand même
c'est de cette façon de s l et j ai
réfléchi extrêmement tasse et je suis
assez lent départ remarquablement
intelligente et il m'a fallu beaucoup
d'animaux sauvages oui non mais il m'a
fallu beaucoup d'années pour comprendre
qu' on ne vend pas par hasard
35 millions de disques il y a quelque
chose qui fait que le paraître n'est pas
ce qui fait vendre
par contre lettres auxquelles je n'étais
jamais intéressé que je dénigre est en
permanence et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
visité celui là faisait qu' il touchait
les gens s'en vont pas 35 millions 10
par hasard comme vous le dites si bien
donc jamais en chansons de marie laforêt
vos noms mais je veux pas qu'ils les
chantiers chalon bc ils sont et pas
quand je vous ai entendu ça c'est sale
et c'est là justement ce qui m'arrive a
pourtant bien revoir ta main
non non c'est parfait ça mais c'est
parfait grâce à du beau fils comment tu
chantais avant et comment tu chantes
maintenant parce que je suis d'obédience
judaïque
oui oui est-ce que moi j'en ai trois
enfants d'accord j'ai chez moi j'ai un
programme et j'ai deborah alors grâce à
dieu mon fils il ya quinze jours
donc oui alors toujours dans le doubs
connaissez quoi elle marie laforêt
thierry ardisson parce que c'est pas
tout posé des questions mais nous avions
capables de nous chanter une chanson
chantée dans la forêt en droit avec du
verre
alors c'est la seule chance aux jo zappé
sur l'album pas avec dix des arts vous
en supplie pas guy béart
moi je l'aimé cela je laime non non non
c'est insupportable c'est beau c'est
beau mais quand même quand il dit des
mariés comme ce sera marié on choisir
ensemble d'accords vous l'aimez bien
guibert j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup autour du changement
maintenant quand son nom
non j'aime beaucoup c'est vraiment un
des rares type extrêmement intelligent
et bien cultiver de ce métier très
intelligent de la finesse de
l'originalité dans ce mondial du meuble
oui oui tout à fait bien sûr que je le
connais bien c'est c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de qualités
mais longtemps vous l'avez vu j'ai
discuté avec charles aznavour qui m'a
dit la même chose
donc il ya peut-être maintenant sûr que
c'est vrai c'est surtout la quête
d'attention c'est surtout un grand
auteur de toute façon oui oui bien sûr
bon alors tu veux donc beaucoup
by antho laisse béat
vous connaissez gilbert koné cette
chanson tu connais pas personnellement
cm vous avisez pas guy béart qua non à
dubaï sali par des balles vous avez
suivi à l'étranger en 1969 dans paris ce
jour toujours étonné comment vous dites
je m'auto punis je voudrais mourir
lentement après avoir beaucoup souffert
ces terribles toujours des trucs à notre
goût donc il avait dit je ne savais pas
encore à ce moment la gréve été violée
ouais c'est ça je n'ai appris très tard
comme ça juste que twin on me voilà sur
ces pays là c'est moi ces déclarations
sont directement issues d'un traumatisme
qui était occulté qui fait que pendant
des années j'ai vécu des choses que je
ne comprenais pas bien je me touche je
m'auto punissait jeu je voulais jamais
être oignons mieux je voulais toujours
disparaître ont beau et dire une chose
comme ça c'est tellement révélateur non
c'est pas terrible
qu'est ce que ça a pris je voudrais
mourir lentement après avoir beaucoup
souffert c'est quand même pas ce que ça
voulait dire j'aime la vie oui oui
c'était s'est il fait il fallait voir ça
en dépit de tout l'amour de la vie était
plus fort que tout don pour m'en séparer
je n'imaginais quinquin supplice
extrêmement lent qui fasse que oui
finalement j'ai envie de mourir oui et
alors quand vous avez révélé ce set face
au traumatisme disons dans dans paris
match c'était l'année dernière je pense
vous avez vous attendiez à être soulagé
en fait je n'ai pas été soulagés en fait
on m'a regardé comme une pestiférée
comme une malade oui le discours des
gens a beaucoup changé visible moi je
connaissais l'événement depuis déjà 10
ans
le fait de le mettre dans le public je
me suis dit qu'un ca devrait libérer
c'est une libération maintenant allez on
envoie en emploi ou loin c'est la batte
de base-ball jeu j'y pense plus je
terminais ouais pas du tout à partir de
là les gens commençaient à parler ça va
oui alors là je me suis dit j'ai vu
vraiment quelque chose de grave
alors que moi j'étais déjà en train d'en
sortir mais on a remise dedans mais là
laurent ça va très bien je vois ça je
vois c'est normal à ce que vous dites
aussi passé par enfin je vous l'avez
déclaré donc donc c'est public hein
c'est pas vous
vous dites que vous sachiez vous ai
longtemps cherché à retrouver
inconsciemment bien sûr avec avec les
hommes cet instant où consob est arrivé
vous avez capitulé c'est à dire me
chercher que les hommes
inconsciemment cette espèce d'abandon
comme ça non c'était pas un abandon
c'était un premier contact
ça a été la première fois qu'on m'a
adressé la parole si j'ose dire
c'était la première phase a été ce
premier contact que j'ai pensé au départ
être un contact amical qui s'est
transformée d'une manière terrible mais
le premier contact était un contact
chaleureux
c'est la première fois que l'on venait
me voir et non pas ma soeur qui avait 10
ans puisque moi ou ma mère en quelqu'un
d'autre c'était moi donc j'ai essayé de
retrouver ça et à chaque fois mais c'est
d'une tristesse en 68 l'abominable c'est
qu'elles aient ou non mais c'est vous
dire que c'est un schéma initial tout
bêtement je vous ai pas été victime de
ce qu'on appelle le syndrome de
stockholm amoureux exactement amoureux
de exactement 6 à 18 ans quand j'en
sentais un dans la foule qui était
vraiment capable de faire beaucoup
souffrir
ouais vous alliez vers les et y attirer
inconsciemment parle par les gens qui
avec y avait un air sympa de l'extérieur
c'est les critiques je voyais
les jantes à l'air sympa escayol qui en
fait sans les ordures voilà c'est comme
ça il ya le trajet dure à l'extérieur et
je suis très sympa mais contrairement à
voir
merci pour moi ça fait toujours plaisir
de présenter une émission à la
télévision était de continuer les est
bien là mais on est bien tous les deux
qu'ils payent mario sepi pour la
télévision absolument bon nombre de
pierres ça me rappelle des souvenirs
ils sont un peu plus forts oui une
dernière
il ya une rumeur terrible qui a couru
sur vous un seul le choix ça peut pas
être pire que tout ce que j'ai entendu
alors on attendait chez madame quoi
c'est celle là c'est celle là oui oui
vous imaginez moi c'est ma ba oui c'est
ça oui mais pourquoi il faut surtout pas
se répéter vous sauriez vous l'auriez vu
je veux dire c'est entièrement honnête
comme je suis mais j'aurais été chez
madame claudie vous seriez marié le
premier jour dans ses portes en soi mais
je le dirai oui oui c'est vrai oui je le
dirige
mais je vous remercie beaucoup